et si vous avez quatre heures de temps
libre en plus par jour
qu'est ce que vous en feriez parce que
14 c'est beaucoup quand on y pense en
quatre heures on fait plein de choses
alors peut-être que vous lirez peut-être
que vous vous apprendriez à coudre et
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
lancerez enfin ce business de corde à
sauter que vous avez toujours voulu
lancer et ben je peux pas répondre à
votre place par contre on va se mettre
d'accord sur un point c'est que vous
auriez un gain en liberté et en
productivité absolument phénoménale et
ben je vais dire une chose c'est que
c'est possible c'est possible en hackant
son sommeil en effet quand on veut
hacker quelque chose la première étape
fondamentale c'est de comprendre de quoi
on parle alors en deux minutes le sommet
qu'est ce que c'est le sommeil c'est
très simple les êtres humains dorment
beaucoup à peu près huit heures par jour
c'est à dire qu'un tiers de l'autre
journée quand même lorsque vous dormez
j'espère que vous le savez mais votre
cerveau fait beaucoup plus que juste
s'éteindre pendant 8 heures lorsque vous
dormez notre cerveau aussi entre
différentes profondeurs de sommeil plus
ou moins intenses on appelle ces rites
on appelle ces périodes les cycles de
sommeil et d'ailleurs on a préparé des
cycles de sommeil comment le sait on le
sait parce qu'il ya plein de recherche
sur le sujet et moi je le sais parce que
j'utilise une petite application très
pratique et ses applications en fait
elle me permet de mesurer mais cycles de
sommeil et du coup elle me donne des
schémas qui ressemble à ça alors ça
c'est très simple à comprendre plus et
au plus je suis réveillé plus est bas
plus furent bernie profondément du coup
en orange je suis réveillé en verre je
suis en sommeil léger et en bleu je suis
dans le sommeil qu'on appelle le soli
profond ou paradoxal vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler du sommeil paradoxal
parce que c'est à ce moment là que l'on
rêve en fait alors je vous ai parlé des
cycles de sommeil
un peu plus tôt et là en fait on les
voit très clairement et on peut en
compter 6 et
c'est un nombre très important c'est
d'ailleurs tellement important qu'on
s'est rendu compte que n'importe quel
être humain avait besoin absolument de
six cycles de sommeil sinon vous êtes
enfin le matin et les chercheurs en
creusant sur ce sujet s'est rendu compte
de quelque chose d'encore plus important
c'est que sur toute cette nuit là eh ben
il ya que la zone en bleu qui sert à
quelque chose
il ya que la zone en bleu qui a une
vertus régénérantes sur votre organisme
c'est à dire que si vous êtes en forme
le matin le vert et le range ça sert à
rien et que le bloc qui compte
et si vous ne croyez pas en faire une
je faire une petite mise en scène pour
vous faire comprendre c'est une
situation qui devrait parler à la
plupart d'entre vous apporte d'alcool
voilà l'idée vous rentrez de soirée vous
êtes parfaitement ivre vous vous et
allez dans votre lit et vous vous
endormez immédiatement comme une enclume
et le lendemain matin vous vous
réveillez et va marquer deux choses
premièrement vous avez un man 2 un mal
de crâne monstrueux deuxièmement vous
est exténué et là vous vous dites oui
sinon valls est belle de boeck
sauf qu'en fait est ce que c'est normal
parce que vous avez dormi de 9 heures à
9 heures c'est largement suffisant dans
une nuit c'est 8h20
vous devriez parfaitement bien et bah
non figuré
que vous avez la chance d'avoir en votre
présence quelqu'un d'extrêmement
professionnels et d' extrêmement
consciencieux
du coup j'ai fait l'expérience j'ai fait
l'expérience
j'ai fait l'expérience et le résultat
est assez parlant voilà ce que ça donne
c'est à dire que là on peut constater
trois choses peut-être 80 première chose
il ya énormément de sommeil léger et je
vous ai expliqué un peu plus tôt que le
sommeil léger était totalement inutile
deuxièmement je me suis réveillé après
une heure et ça bien sûr j'en ai aucun
souvenir
et troisièmement et le plus important
c'est ça c'est que je suis passé de 6
cycles de sommeil profond à seulement 3
ou est ce que ça veut dire
c'est à dire que lorsque votre cerveau
et embrumées ça vous votre cerveau vous
l'alcool en fait empêche votre cerveau
d'avoir des cycles réguliers et c'est
pour ça que vous êtes totalement exténué
le matin alors cet exemple en plus de
vous amuser
serra deux choses principalement à vous
expliquer que l'être humain a besoin de
deux heures de sommeil profond
c'est tout si vous n'avez pas buzzer
vous êtes fatigués et de plus seul le
sommeil profond et utile et c'est là que
je remets ma casquette de hackers parce
que ce que je vous dis depuis tout à
l'heure là c'est que vous avez huit
heures de sommeil mais qui en a que deux
qui servent à quelque chose
il y aurait pas quelque chose à faire là
bas si en fait il ya quelque chose à
faire et on appelle ça le sommeil police
physique le sommeil poli physique qu'est
ce que c'est ça va être compliqué la
semaine politique
c'est la discipline qui vise à diminuer
le temps sommeil en divisant ce dernier
grâce à des petites siestes pendant la
journée
alors ça peut paraître très compliqué
comme ça mais ça n'est pas du tout et
c'est même tellement simple que vous
tous vous avez déjà eu un rythme de
sommeil politique quand ça parce que
vous n'étiez bébé parce que figurez vous
qu'un bébé en fait n'a pas encore été
formaté boulot n'en fait toujours
mauvais sens pas encore été formaté
métro boulot dodo par la société et par
ses parents et par conséquent le bébé
dort quand il veut c'est à dire que
souvent il va faire une grossiste dans
l'après midi
ensuite il va être en pleine forme on va
le mettre au lit à 8 heures et il s'est
réveillé à 3h du matin au grand malheur
des parents
et ça qu'est ce que ça montre
premièrement ça montre que on peut se
dire oui c'est le bébé qui n'a pas un
rythme naturel alors qu'en fait non
c'est contraire c'est nous qui avons un
rythme imposé par la société et c'est le
bébé qui fait ce qu'il veut et tient un
rythme naturel
je prends un deuxième exemple les
skippers en mer est ce que vous êtes
déjà demandé comment un skipper en
solitaire faisait pour faire des
traversées de 90 jours presque sans
dormir
bah moi je suis japonais la question est
d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé la réponse
et comment ils font pas c'est très
simple les gars pousse le sommeil
polyphonique à l'extrême c'est à dire
que la journée au plus tôt la nuit à la
demande lui d'un skipper en mer va
ressembler à ça quand c'est en rouge il
orne quand c'est en blanc ils sont
réveillés
c'est à dire que les mecs ils ont six
siestes de 20 minutes dans la journée et
que ça leur suffit peuple e66 de 20
minutes
si vous vous souvenez ça fait deux
heures c'est à dire exactement les deux
heures de sommeil profond dont on a
besoin
et qu'est ce que ça montre et bah ça
montre tout simplement que ces mecs là
optimisent leur sommeil à 100% c'est à
dire qu'ils sont réveillés 22 heures par
jour et que ça leur pose pas de problème
alors cela dit ils ne tiennent jamais ce
genre de rythme pendant plus de trois
mois parce qu'après on ne sait pas
encore si ça a des conséquences
négatives sur la santé et un rythme
aussi extrêmes et violent ça en aurait
certainement est bien là en fait j'ai
pris deux exemples diamétralement
opposées et on va prendre un troisième
exemple prend un peu plus banal un peu
plus normale
et cet exemple c'est moi alors retour
trois en arrière lorsque j'étais au
lycée en terminale
à l'époque j'avais absolument aucune
confiance en moi j'avais une estime
nullissime de ma personne j'avais aucune
vie sociale et jeu
scheer les jeux vidéo pour justifier
cette absence de vie sociale enfin bref
j'étais un ado parfaitement normal et le
truc c'est que à la fin du lycée il faut
s'orienter
mais vu que je n'ai pas confiance en moi
je me disais non non la prépa c'est pas
du tout pour moi et du coup je me dis ok
qu'est ce qui m'intéresse il ya plein de
choses qui m'intéressait pour tout vous
dire à un moment j'ai même hésité entre
être pilote d'hélicoptère et forgeron du
coup j'ai essayé de faire un truc
beaucoup plus original et j'ai fait une
école de commerce
mais je sais personne n'est parfait mais
ça va voilà donc toujours est il que je
voulais en école de commerce mais je
voulais pas faire de prépa j'ai été
obligée d'aller vers les post bac et les
post bac elles sont assez particulière
parce qu on y accède après un concours
sauf que à l'époque bas c'était pas pour
moi les concours parce que ça me faisait
peur et du coup je me suis dit oh les
grégoire dont la devise est large
du coup j'ai mis la première la deuxième
et la troisième est la septième ce qui
fait que en janvier avant le
baccalauréat
j'avais quatre concours à préparer écrit
comment et en plus de celles
baccalauréat alors aujourd'hui je
regarde ça et je me dis bon c'est pas la
mer à boire
sauf qu'à l'époque bas c'était un peu
l'épreuve de ma vie voilà quoi et puis
ce qui s'est passé ensuite c'est que je
me disais ok grégoire ça sent aussi ça
sent le roussi tu vas te planter parce
que tu as eu les dieux beaucoup plus
gros que le ventre
et du coup ben je me disais c'est pas
gagné et puis là j'ai un ami qui comme
moi aiment mes trucs bizarres qui est
venu me voir et il m'a parlé du sommeil
poli physique
il m'a parlé de sommeil poli physique il
m'a expliqué les tenants et les
aboutissants et il m'a dit que si
j'étais motivé ben on pouvait tenter
l'expérience et à ce moment là dans ma
tête voilà ce qui s'est passé je me suis
dit ok grégoire si tu continues comme ça
tu fonce dans le mur et tu veux pas y
arriver
super positif de 7 et du coup je me suis
dit ok alors pourquoi pas tenter
l'expérience et geste a pas je me suis
ajouté à moi même et puis ça se trouve
un jour tu pourra en parler dans une
conférence et des gens trouveront ça
cool mais ça c'est un voile à part on
verra et c'est exactement
ce que j'ai fait c'est à dire que j'en
ai parlé à mon père mon père trouvait ça
cool j'ai parlé à ma mère ma mère était
absolument horrifiés par l'idée sauf que
papa est médecin
alors pour moi c'était feu vert j'allais
rester en vie chic c'était parti j'étais
parti en janvier pour trois mois de
sommeil poli physique
alors j'ai eu un rythme qu'on appelle le
rythme every man qui est assez
particulier parce qu'il est structurée
d'une telle manière à ce que l'on puisse
maintenir un semblant de vie sociale je
vois si bien semblant c'est simple c'est
une grosse nuit de trois heures souvent
de quatre heures à 7 heures du mat
c'est la partie qui fait plaisir en fait
puis trois petites siestes de 20 minutes
réparties à différents moments de la
journée et là ça va être à des heures
comme midi 16h et minuit
alors j'ai bien dit un semblant de vie
sociale parce qu'elles peuvent aller au
lycée à l'époque devait aller en cours
et à l'époque à 16h et à midi je vais
trouver des endroits où dormir et je
peux vous dire que je me suis fait
plusieurs fois déloger des wc par les
surveillants
parce que je devais m'en fermé aux wc
pour prendre à venir tranquillement
c'était le seul endroit du lycée et
c'est pas simple d'expliquer un
surveillant qu'on doit sans fermer aux
chiottes
parce que parce qu'il ya trop de bruit
en salle de permanence en fait certains
pas simple donc c'était pas facile tous
les jours je vais pas le cacher mais par
contre c'était incroyable pourquoi
c'était incroyable pour ça parce que
j'estime que en faisant ça j'ai
économisé environ 120 heures par mois je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte mais
si vous faites un petit taf de
consultant à 20 euros de l'heure
ça fait 2000 400 euros par mois c'est
quand même un petit acteur il me semble
en voilà sauf que bien sûr à l'époque je
n'avais pas de quoi être un consultant
du coup je me suis content d être un
étudiant et j'ai travaillé j'ai lu j'ai
étudié j'ai regardé documentaires et des
films
et maintenant que je regarde ça je me
dis c'est clairement regarde ça ça mais
bon j'ai eu mon bac mais ça je serais
pas là sinon c'est clairement car c'est
ça que j'ai eu mon bac et que j'ai eus
l'école dans laquelle je sais
aujourd'hui
maintenant aujourd'hui
et et j'ai arrêté les sonneries
polyphoniques et la question
intéressante c'est pourquoi parce que si
c'était si génial que ça si je pouvais
perdre de 1400 euros par mois net en
consultant je le ferais c'est ça sauf
qu'en fait non la raison pour laquelle
j'ai arrêté c'est que j'avais atteint
mes objectifs c'est à dire que j'avais
plus raison de le battre en fait en
quelque sorte c'était pas une grande
bataille c'était une petite bataille à
mon échelle mais j'avais plus de raison
de me battre j'avais atteint mes
objectifs et du cloud bas c'était un peu
de vacances et en fait c'est ça le
message c'est qu'il me croire sur celle
là
si moi je peux le faire tout le monde
peut le faire franchement le seul truc
qui nous manque à tous c'est d'avoir
faim c'est d'avoir le seul dénominateur
commun qui nous manque à tous pour
réussir à faire ce genre de choses pour
réussir à se faire violence pendant en
retire se faire violence et à sacrifier
quatre heures de sons de son sommeil par
jour
bah c'est d'avoir en permanence cette
fin cette sensation désagréable dans les
tripes que si jamais vous ne changez pas
radicalement vous allez jouer et c'est
peut-être un peu malicieux de vous
souhaiter ça mais au fond c'est le cas
je vous le souhaite je vous souhaite
d'avoir faim parce qu'au fond plus on a
faim on est content de passer à table
merci